The incredible Shonda Rhimes
created a cultural phenomenon with "Bridgerton."
Who is into "Bridgerton"?
Hi, we love it.
(audience cheering)
And now "The Kit" reports "Bridgerton" is going bridal.
Fashion experts say brides are looking
for a Regency-era touch
for their wedding dresses.
Empire waistlines, delicately-embroidered flowers,
and bows for days, bows!
And, hey, if the pearls fit, then wear them, honey,
especially on your wedding day.
Don't you think?
I mean, maybe, Drew, my wedding's coming up.
Maybe I'll be in a girdle.
Or a corset
Or a corset, yeah.
I'd love to see you in a corset.
Or like the wig that the queen wears on "Bridgerton."
I mean, you and I,
we've gotten to interview people from "Bridgerton,"
we've talked about "Bridgerton" on the news.
We always do a little donning,
a little nod to.
Always a veil, mhmm.
Well, speaking of whimsical weddings,
our next story comes from "The Knot."
That's right, we've got their cover boy
for their summer issue right here,
and it's our very own Ross Mathews.
Look at that!
(audience cheering)
Oh my God.
Let's peek inside!
(audience cheering)
Look at that.
Me and my Welly.
(audience clapping)
Now this is obviously Ross,
and that is Wellington, Ross's fiance.
And guess who's actually here today?
Welly, hi, Welly!
(audience cheering)
Oh, my Welly's here.
Come join us up at the desk.
(audience clapping)
Oh.
Look at my Welly.
You guys here me talk about him all the time.
Here he is, sit here.
Oh, okay.
Now let me ask you guys a question,
because I will say,
and by the way, I'm the flower girl at the wedding, so.
She is, she is.
I know, isn't that exciting?
I have my dress upstairs, it's so special.
But you guys just look like you're having so much fun
in your engagement.
Like are you guys enjoying it
as much as we feel it and see it?
Yes.
Yeah, we are.
We're so thrilled to be on the cover of "The Knot"
and talking about it here on your show, Drew, our show,
because it's important to us to share
our love with the world.
And we made a conscious decision to do that because why?
Well, because growing up immigrant
from Dominican Republic,
and him being a little farm boy from Mount Vernon,
we never saw that.
And it's important to actually have
that representation out there
and just value that anyone can actually have that as well.
So excited.
Growing up, but think about that.
We didn't even dream about getting married one day,
because it wasn't even an option for us, you know?
And so we think by sharing our love story
and showing it to everyone
maybe there's a little kid out there
who can look at us and go,
"Oh my God, I deserve that, I deserve love."
Aw!
(audience clapping)
And the energy
that you put into it
is just such a loving energy,
but also having fun.
Yes.
Yeah.
And every time I see you guys doing your thing
it reminds me to enjoy life more.
Yeah?
It really does.
It's so inspiring.
That's the nicest thing, Drew, oh.
We love you.
I love you guys too.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
That's the cutest.
That is the biggest compliment you can give us, right?
It's true, that's what I get from you guys
just as an innocent bystander and right in the middle of it.
It's both.
Yeah.
We're just so grateful.
Especially, where we come from,
growing up as little gay kids
was not the easiest thing in the world,
and the world in itself has been
sort of a dark place lately.
And so to have this sort of joy,
we're filled with gratitude
and we just wanna share it with everybody.
Welly, can I ask you a question?
Absolutely.
'Cause I get to be with
my lucky co-pilot all the time,
who is your co-pilot
in life.
In life, yes.
What is it that you really admire in Rossy?
Tell me one thing you admire about him.
And then, I have a follow up question.
Just one?
Oh, good answer.
Oh!
That's good.
We didn't even rehearse this, that's good.
No, his heart.
Drew, you know, his heart is just so loving
and just he gives it to everyone.
And, honestly, he's just the sweetest person
that I've ever met.
And his humor, that's why I have to say more than one.
And you and him have this chemistry that just like,
I want you to know how much you mean to us honestly,
and we love you so much.
And because of you is why
we are in the same state right now.
Ah, I'm so relieved,
because I am totally third-wheeling it with you guys.
And also it's like, which I like,
I like being a third wheel.
Yeah, we're like a wheel,
but come on, join in, tricycle.
Yeah, exactly, a tri is stronger.
Mhmm, we are the hottest throuple on daytime television.
And you know that throuples are trending!
So everybody look for this beautiful issue on newsstands.
It'll be everywhere April 26th.
Well, guess what?
The people from "The Knot" are here!
Right here!
(audience cheering)
Look at that.
(audience clapping)
Yay, thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you for making this happen.
I just wanna say too, as a lover of magazines,
I just think this cover is so beautiful,
the inside, and I am such a big fan of "The Knot."
(upbeat music)